[Music]  what is he doing parking  parallel to what  nothing works you know that you're gone  [Music]  I brought you some food okay bye are you  always this unfriendly I am not  unfriendly okay you're like a warm  cuddle  what is that looks like it's yours now  Otto you are not taking over my bed  you think you have to do everything on  your own but no one can you can't stand  watching One idiot try to teach another  how to drive it's lesson time  clutch in and break break the car is  stopped I almost hit the car Mr Ryan's  hybrid my life was black and white she's  always going to be with you  [Music]  my father used to smile like that I'm  not smart exactly  [Music]  I have a cat  foreign